I am a dad of three kids and my kids are
now at school
and the more that I'm seeing first hand
the way that
I'm now realizing the more I was lied to
as a kid and I think every
way that we are
by the media by the education system by
the government the status quo it is
crazy and how untrue it is I can't
believe people still buy in to the bull
crap that is taught in schools and in
the media you know it's just nonsense so
I'm going to share some of the things
I'm gonna challenge some of the things
that you might believe to be true when
is actually not so and I'm going to
start right from school and I'm gonna go
right up till retirement and this video
might change your life it might change
the course of your life the whole
direction of your life because it's not
just about what you know and learning
new things it's also about unlearning
some of the nonsense that we've been
taught that's actually Incorrect and I'm
speaking as somebody that makes millions
of pounds every single year to failed in
school that failed in just about
everything that I was told would help me
become successful flunked out of school
age 16 never went to University and
um the banks
that this is another thing the banks and
the government and the schools and the
education system and the media and I
don't want to sound like a conspiracist
or anything but they're all singing this
the same song and people are buying into
it the masses are buying into it and
it's keeping people flat broke poor so
first thing is this at school at school
they teach you certainly for me I can
only speak from my experience that your
exams are the bill and end all
and you spent what 16 years of your
entire life working on getting good
exams
okay fine now listen I don't want to
demotivate kids I have this problem with
my kids I don't want to save them don't
try at school but I'm thinking man I was
like sweating losing sleep over the fact
that I I might not get better grades and
you think don't you think that if you
get bad school grades your whole life is
going to be terrible afterwards
it's not okay
um
schools teach you
ultimately to comply you know what
schools are actually teaching you to be
they're teaching you to be brilliant
employees you want to be a good employee
go to school they'll teach you to
conform don't challenge don't question
things put your hand up when you want to
go to the toilet work hard don't work
smart don't copy someone else's work
that's cheating that's not cheating
that's called being smart find someone
smart and see what they did that's what
you do in business
they would tell you not to use a
calculator certainly when I was at
school don't use a calculator that's
cheating what in business you always use
a calculator don't rely on Mental Math
but it could be flawed so the whole
school system and this is the thing that
really gets me okay I have tried
relentlessly to bring financial literacy
into schools in the UK I have created
curriculums I have banged on doors I
have tried
but they actually don't want that
because imagine if kids would talk about
Finance at school imagine if kids were
taught about passive income oh
at school they were like so what what
why do I need to go get a job and trade
my time for money and work for 2 000
pounds a month for 40 years for 40 hours
a week to then retire on 40 of what I
couldn't afford to live on in the first
place when I can just make 2 000 pounds
in passive income from one good deal why
don't I spend all my time trying to find
one good deal even if it takes me three
years to find that good deal bang then
I've got the passive income they don't
want kids knowing that they don't want
kids understanding the difference
between assets and liabilities why not
because it's brainwashing because then
when you leave school you go to
university which is going to help you
get a job
right and then when you get a job
now it's a case of right now work hard
for my boss
I put into a pension I save up as much
money as I can and I put that money
where in the bank and this is where the
banks come in on it because this is the
thing the more people
that have got money saved in the bank
for a rainy day 20 grand 30 grand I'm
talking okay that's the best if one
person as far as the bank's concerned if
one rich person like me has three
million pounds in that's a problem why
because that rich person might say can I
get my three mil back please by the way
I've done this I've gone to the bank
because it can have my millions and
they've said wow we can only give you
five grand a day it freaks them out why
does it freak them out because of
something called fractional Reserve
banking what is fractional Reserve
banking fractional Reserve banking is a
legal law where the banks are allowed to
invest the money that you put in the
bank and they invest it themselves and
go make a ton of money so you put 100
Grand in the bank they'll take at least
90 grand of that and they'll invest it
they'll loan it out they'll invest it in
stocks and shares they'll invest it in
real estate and they'll see a Sky High
return they'll probably make 20 30 50
100 return on investment and they'll
give you 0.2 percent
so of course
the banks want people to work hard be
employees and then put that money in the
bank for a rainy day because them if
they've got millions of people that have
all got 20 30 Grand in the bank then
they can then run a billion pound
business off the back of it
so the banks want you to think that of
course they do right so the idea of
having money in the bank and you know
what as well I I mean I can't believe
this when I started getting a lot of
money I started thinking what happens if
my bank does bust
if I got 3 million in the bank if the
bank goes bust what happens what happens
is you're only insured up to the first
85 Grand the rest you lose so the whole
concept of like investing in A bank's
really safe it's kind of not the whole
concept of having a job is much safer
than having a business and it's kind of
not you know how many people have been
made redundant and just fired at a good
job for life doesn't exist the average
person by the age of 40 goes to over two
dozen jobs like it's just not but people
still believe it they're still hanging
on to this concept you know and then and
then what and then you've invest into
property and of course the system wants
you to not invest into property they
want you to buy a house with your
feelings because there's a dumb deal and
the Dumber the deal the better
and they of course want you to live in
the house not rent it out
how do they stop you buying houses to
rent out the first thing they do is they
tax the crap out of you so if you're if
you're an amateur investor or just an
average person and you buy a house to
rent it out you're going to get hit with
section 24 tax which doesn't apply for
the rich folks doesn't apply for the big
companies only for the amateurs so you
get smacked with tax also they
incentivize people to buy a house to
live in it with things like help to buy
lifetime Isa right to buy right to Buy's
got some pretty good perks to be fair
like right to buy but help to buy them
lifetime answers are a scam in my
opinion because let me explain help to
buy
which is what if you know it makes me
laugh so much because people when I
started out in property investment when
I was like 17 everyone was like shocked
oh this is so risky oh my gosh you're
going on a property course and you're
spending thousands of pounds to get
mentored that is so risky meanwhile
they're going to University to study
drama
and everyone's clapping them
you're going to stay oh you're a good
boy at school oh you're getting a job
that's so safe whoa Samuel you're gonna
get into business you're investing in
products so risky it's just like
ridiculous and again it's because of the
brainwashing people are like sheep they
read the newspapers so where was I
helped to buy yeah help to buy what is
help to buy help to buy is where the
government help you to buy a property
why do they want you to buy a property
because they want you to buy a property
not as an investment they want you to
buy a property to live in why because if
you're buying a property that you live
in it makes you 10 times more likely to
not want to quit your job
let me explain
you're renting a house you're paying a
grand a month rent it's cool you can
start a business worst case you can
always move into a cheaper you can move
into a room shower or an apartment
you're renting it's cool but you're you
own a house now you're locked down
you've got responsibility you've got
security but security comes with
responsibility and now you'll be
thinking man if I start a business and
it doesn't work and then I get fired and
I've got my mortgage I've got this rope
around my neck so they want that to
happen because the more afraid you are
the more like a sheep you are and the
less like you likely you are to be
entrepreneurial and you might say but
why would they not want you to be
entrepreneurs well if they wanted you to
be entrepreneurs would they not at least
have one class at school one mandatory
class that talk the basics of investment
and business but they don't
nothing so
helped by so the government helped you
how do they help you they help you by
giving you the majority of the deposit
which means you've only got to put down
five percent deposit the rest
you'll get from the government
and people think that sounds good it's
not it's terrible why number one because
you have to live in the house you can't
rent it out which means it's a liability
it's not an asset because it's not
making you any money it's a rope around
your neck I invest in property I invest
in properties that make me money because
I rent them out and they give me cash
flow but if you're living in yourself
you're not making cash flow number two
it only applies to new build homes
why new build hunts
because the rich are the people that
create the rules and it's not really the
help to buy scheme really it's the help
to sell skin the scheme is created for
rich people that want to build and
develop properties but are worried that
they won't be able to sell them at the
end
so the help to buy scheme is really the
help to sell skin see it's a case with
all of these schemes
also you have to pay the government back
so it's not like they're giving you the
money it's about that in full
what does that and also with new builds
do you know what happens when you buy a
brand new build house it drops in value
by 10 straight away because it's no
longer a new build
so the government to help move over help
to buy no you're buying it you're
borrowing the money from the government
but then your debt on the house is
suddenly more than the house itself
because the value of the house drops now
you're in negative equity now you really
better be a good boy and stick around at
your job and get a promotion
so
it's all lies the media are all lies now
when I say the media relies technically
they might say we're not lying because
what they do is they do things like
they'll say allegedly
but the sentence is a lie but you you
can't you can't you can't sue them or
say anything because they'll just say no
no we said allegedly
One Source said and then they'll tell
their lie
what do you mean One Source said who
said it name the person some random
person on the street and then the media
can then literally publish the story and
just say One Source said be careful what
you read in the newspapers and everyone
wants to retire
and then they retire and they're 69
years old and then they realize they got
to the top of the ladder and they climb
the wrong ladder now retire when they're
69 years old and then they have to go
get a paper round to top up the bills
because Energy prices tripled but wages
didn't we've been liked it